hi Jimmy oh my god Jimmy car has arrived
I believe yeah we were talking about
we're talking about getting the wrong
subway go to Brooklyn just when you
think you have a city worker I'm such a
tourist you [ __ ] up although I've
gotta say my accent is bulletproof for
getting lost in a strange city well
excuse me do you know the way they
nearly sold me Manhattan again Oh we'll
take you they wanted you negate Korean
ladies took me did you have that moment
on the subway where you go do you know
when this is getting to 50th Street and
they go and the young man who stopped
masturbating briefly this is the right
train never I'm telling you I've never
jerked off on the train that's clearly
not true I can't believe you don't like
if you search now if you just think for
five minutes Jim I know there'll be an
occasion any mode of public transport
he said train space it's a bus maybe of
course first time I was in first class
so enjoy it you were yeah it was great
yeah Jim left behind his little gift to
usher in the bathroom they're not
mutually exclusive I started in the
bathroom and then [ __ ] finished back
at the seat yeah someone sold a blanket
but its first class remember an
acceptable first you're right yeah paid
for the right but who would start
jerking why would you go oh I'm about to
finish let me go back to my seat that's
why you did a show-off
did you really like think to yourself I
got to go back to my seat before I blow
my load you know that mile-high club
there's a certain cachet but basically
what you're saying is we [ __ ] in a
chemical toilet first of all you're
gross but yes right a plainness romantic
is it some maybe I've never done it I
don't know I mean a lot better but you
know when you're on a tour bus and
there's a there's a a
bathroom the back and it's just the
grossest thing in the world yeah but
somehow exactly the same as an airplane
yeah well that's why Jim was like I will
not lower myself to finishing in this
bathroom I'm gonna go back to my seat
like a gentleman and that's where I'll
ejaculate this guy he's not gonna read
some Hmong Smith
are you aware there was an election last
night I'm not really up on the news but
have you covered that we did talk about
it yeah I did today yeah yeah did you
not body didn't talk you didn't vote
she didn't I could have voted and didn't
you could have voted it in well I guess
you know what happening in New York that
I'm Canadian I feel like I do the most
frustrated I've ever been in the news
now basically our news is your news we
just get a trial is the only story it's
done 24 hours a day it's the oh he's the
only news story the whole time and we
have no say in this madness but you have
all kinds of like brags it and whatnot
going on there so we can make our own
bad decisions don't you worry about that
but I would like to have a dog in the
race on this one right I ended up
betting on the currency just to be just
to get excited about it just be
interested you bought stock I bought I
bought futures
I bet basically that the dollar would be
weaker against the pound after this this
election oh well no no it'll be fine
it's we're trying to leave the largest
trading block in the world but they're
patting us on the top of the head to go
oh okay
you can have your sovereignty just sign
here here and here it's gonna be exactly
you guys leaving or no what we're
leaving but I mean we're not leaving the
Trading though well I think I think they
kind of do I think the papers are just
kind of running with the story is just
so kind of disaster sells papers so they
about it being a disaster it'll be
absolutely fine you won't notice any
difference you aren't I mean yeah I mean
you couldn't point to on a map so that's
a different she is really yeah when you
oh well there you go
past an answer so I don't know well no
one knows
yeah but I'm not walking around telling
people I'm amazing at geography I think
it might be Vilnius Vilnius is my guess
and anyone listening that's gonna Google
that I mean you didn't know either right
exactly
how about this what's the capital of
Africa amazing question mark amazing a
level of ignorance question mr. Kaster
nailed way to go so capital a Kenya oh
do you know if that's true or not I said
I know he's look at me just to check
it's a weird thing though when you get
all stone as you go well if you've sent
with enough confidence ya know aerobic
capital of Egypt are you just asking
capitals yeah sure go ahead
hmm yeah that is your fancy oh she's a
Montreal you speak fluent French are you
on the wrong show you might be on the
wrong why do French action normally
action she do French action French
action but they normally don't get met
with grunts by the host why I like to
kiss upper arm like [ __ ] The Addams
Family by God but you figured out the
city now oh oh oh
undoubted you're good to go sadly I also
spent a delightful five minutes in Fox
News trying to convince them to let me
on the Jim Norton show slightly
confusing I went in there and I was very
surly with me yes
I'd like to seen Jim Norton no how is
Howard townhall the Town Hall was an I
saw I did a show last night in a Miss
New York Comedy Festival thing this week
and it was an absolute joy yeah like
it's a crowd that you don't get in the
you light something about American
audiences where they're much more giving
but like you're right right have done
like 40 countries this year and in
America there's a thing with they laugh
at joke they've enjoyed the joke and
then they'll throw a little applause
break in there yeah they'll throw a
little thang train by TV that's a TV
training but the new Europe they'll go
they'll watch the whole thing I did gigs
in Finland recently which the whole show
I thought this is gone
very very poorly there they're listening
politely n to the end of the show they
went nuts because they think they can
they're happy it was over between a
standing ovation of people getting yeah
I think I got standing ovations hang on
[Laughter]
yeah if it's the TV training the
applause that comes after the laughing
yeah you can watch the Carlin a special
called you are all disease and there's
one moment where there it's a great
specialties movie the greatest yeah
they're clapping and he goes okay okay
and you could see the it's [ __ ] his
timing up he didn't want the applaud it
he didn't need the applause you could
see it it [ __ ] up timing for jokes
right where do you stand on the on the
uncle on the walking off and walking
back on as if you weren't going to I've
never done an encore never never done oh
no no I don't do the my duty closing bet
you don't do them cook that's different
yeah he's never better call for it Kate
took her her heavy sweater off and is
now just wearing a very like the
delightful striped shirt Kate is now
wearing a tight t-shirt and while you
were taking your while you were taking
your over garment off Jim mumbled yes
yes I wanted you to become just to make
sure everybody's on board with
everything are you really do you are
deodorant I realize I realized in any
other work setting saying saying I wear
do you wear deodorant this is getting
very sexual in its not know I'm anti
deodorant yeah aunty you wear it kind of
like when women here's what you didn't
know yeah I knew that the correct answer
was no if you had said no you would have
driven this man into such a fervor
incredible so you like a bit of musk at
times not sure if you could refrain from
undressing me with your eyes
super Bri or smell good though but you
don't mind having your head shoved into
an armpit that's maybe been walking
around Manhattan all
they I could live with that depends if
they're clean I don't like dirty feet
little smelly is fine but they gotta be
clean like I don't like to feed they
don't walk on the floor have I got a top
tip for you Jim have you tried the B
train because if you enjoy smelly people
you are in love
that was some some guys there just
decided sharing was not for them yeah
there's a lot of them but you don't like
stink you just like the natural body
odor yeah I don't want dirty right not
dirty clothes yeah but what if
somebody's been like like let's say
somebody was going through the New York
City Marathon over the shore and that
was just on Sunday and they decided that
right before they shower they really
needed to go ahead and have a sit on
your face would that be okay it would be
a reward for their their hard-won I'll
be like just relax take a load off
so we're not just talking about the
election then yeah no not entirely
okay yeah we're actually loading we're
so looking around the issues yeah okay
yeah no sure you know we're gonna loop
back to it though I promise you that
we're getting there but you you don't
say yeah you don't mind sweaty ass crack
either depends on the person honestly
how deeply going on this deep dive into
ass crack how deep we go and I thought
that two knuckles is the gentleman's
measure oh yes so are you I mean getting
back to the show the the election is
this is what we're talking about are you
invested in it because it's on the news
so much or do you just know I put a Fed
home right to get invested because I
mean it's on the news I don't care I
don't like do you guys now okay I mean
it seemed like it seems that
everything's going in one direction in
the world and we're having a little you
know a lot everything since the turn of
the century has gone in one direction
it's like there's more freedom and more
liberty and everything's getting better
and we've kind of gone oh we need as you
ever four years off from that but that's
at four years off and just have a little
look around and then we'll go again
yeah let's back that up a little bit
yeah yeah nothing's been done I was
chatting last night nothing's been done
since 2010 right what new laws have been
passed repealed just some things have
been required of regulations have been
repealed they put those kids in cages
yeah earlier so that's not bad okay
oh did we not all okay it's a narrow
militia walking towards the border now
they have depending on what channel you
watch it's either a militia or a caravan
of peaceful yes they're either tuckered
out or they're carrying machetes a
Warner they're walking towards the
border yeah but they're like 800 miles
away do you think there's any so so
these are these are people trying to get
into America
and then there's militia men trying to
stop them no one's happy them yet but
they may be at the at the border waiting
you're right about that that the militia
men are being prepared to stop the this
isn't happening or this is a new series
on FX to replace walking dead right
right no it's happening it's I love the
idea with the whole border the whole
thing around that the idea that people
are going this is a huge issue when you
go have you checked the airports I it's
it's mind-boggling to be standing there
with a rifle looking up going oh it's a
plane someone could be on that
well the airports though there's a
documentation that goes on where you get
on the plane right they have to know you
have a visa whatever before you get on
the plane they're worried about the
people just jumping just going right
over the border and running into our
country undocumented I think it's like
weird that George Soros is funding this
and he won't give him a [ __ ] bus it's
finding the caravan yeah he's like y'all
pay for it because I walk in give you
new shoes every thousand miles yeah we
have guys on the sidelines handing out
orange slices as you go but other than
that no that's it I didn't know he was
funding it now that's I mean I've heard
I think Bonnie got the wrong building is
well you need Fox News series in crazy
broad nature obviously I don't believe
it I'm joking I mean but but people do
say that oh yeah body believes that she
does my hundred-percent he's pushing
that are you still married to that guy I
sure AM
I'm not really cuz I he's not she's
loving every minute of it you're happily
in love with Rachel yes whenever he goes
away I'm half
I see then when he comes back I get
irritated why do you not think that
binding should be married to rich vos I
mean in terms of in the history of
people punching above their way forces I
mean he's killing it right he's in the
world knows right I mean no but he would
never admit to that he's constantly like
letting you know how lucky you are
come on well Troy and I are very
supportive of the fact that he wears he
has these tiny little stumpy fingers
buddy crazy would he look with
normal-sized fingers he's full foot too
no that's true you're a guy but his
fingers could be a little longer but he
wears big giant rings on each of it I
like them Bryce
Bonnie said you pulled that two knuckles
yeah I was walking in the street and
people were staring at me I think it
might have been the crown I love when he
put the Cologne on you better see what
they gave him a little cologne kit yeah
Gavin Cologne on his neck with John with
John William Hurt and but you were doing
the Elephant Man impression and the list
was exactly the same as Jimmy Carter
have you stumbled upon to something I
think is rich boss the Elephant Man yeah
I think how do you feel about vos
deciding that he needs to display his
wealth through physical means on his
fingers letting the world know how
successfully I want you know like a
medieval gypsy right I wanted him to
express himself however he feels best
express himself but sometimes it is like
I'm human so sometimes when we're out or
like we're doing stuff we're talking to
someone you know maybe we're at the
doctor's something where they're I see
locates and then you're like do you
worry that there's gonna be we've been
looking for a house so as soon as we go
and in the realtor normal sized house or
doesn't the things have to be specially
there's stools but for little little
lies little rings thinks that's gonna
get like a thing is classier he thinks
like he bought me a Louis Vuitton one
time I well I have a tongue I asked and
he gets so mad if I don't wear it cuz he
he feels that's how people will know
you're doing well that's it we tell them
every time you have to show it's like
rappers so you have to show that you're
wealthy through physical means otherwise
how will anybody have any way you like
your Louis Vuitton whatever it was bag
well it's like a thousand dollar bag I'm
a [ __ ] comedian I throw it in the
corner and go on stage like it's not
it's just it's not a good idea
no yeah it is now do you feel like when
your daughter is of college age mhm and
you guys have to tell her it's time for
you to go get some student loans and her
dad is telling her to get student loans
why he'll be dead by then will melt down
his ring no no I don't well this is the
other thing he buys me jewelry all the
time he bought me this shoot like
honestly it was like this thick of a
like a gold neck like a Run DMC wrote to
me like you see me I wear no jewelry
none I like he keeps buying me these
wedding rings that are enormous and then
I'm I won't wear them I said I'll wear
for a special occasion and he's like you
word all the time that's what it's for
because he thinks this is a bad
reflection on him is he helping people
on the way home no he how was this
jewelry coming is it like just just in
the palm of his hand a lot of time in
the
in the diamond district I think he likes
negotiating that's why you have all this
jewelry cuz he loves a deal he gets a
deal on it he's like I'll buy it if I
can get a deal on yeah yeah so then he
takes it and gets it remade into jewelry
for himself I think it's like a way of
him Johnny what he wants but being a
great guy I remember a cheese blog
saying the same thing is that right oh
yeah how come you have no jewelry you
don't like it I don't wear jewelry I
tried it in high school and I don't like
it either him there's the issue that you
just don't have anybody if somebody were
to buy you jewelry would you like that I
agree I don't like being adorned with I
don't know my looks speak for themselves
they do oh my goodness
well Jimmy Carr I'm glad you made it
we have to wrap up though really Josh
show ends before you are actually with
this show even end
I mean it's battler driving
cross-country running prostitutes in the
back of trucks absolutely need something
very something to listen to take their
mind off it they need entertainment also
to keep the screaming out you know
because they don't kill him right away
he called them back there of course god
bless these long-distance Rovers god
bless you lights